questa impronta proprio fresca vuol dire
che la creatura è passata qua
recentemente
chi viene morso da un lupo mannaro e
condannato a divenire un lupo mannaro la
sua volta ecco lo sapevo e adesso
[Musica]
speriamo che non torni più per tutta la
notte adesso
melissa velista qualcuno sta bussando
alla porta ma si affitta
sembra abitare abbiamo facemmo un
insulto e ancora trasformato il lupo
mannaro può coprire questi vorrei aprire
la porta magari sito sei più esperta in
fatto di lupo mannaro quindi forse è
meglio che happy to
mi sento che siete va dentro apritevi
sparita
[Musica]
normale
sì mi ricordo di me è sparito non c'è
più il morso la raf è ritornato
completamente normale sì ma io mi
ricordo che il lungo ieri aveva morso di
certo ce lo ricordiamo benissimo per
librino di coprire la mortarino non avrò
uno non apriamo la porta e pericoloso no
state calmi tranquilli non c'è bisogno
di spaventarsi né di agitarsi adesso è
tutto a posto superiore ma non avere
paura di tranquillo lui comunque sta
ancora dormendo ancora nella sanità e
quindi è tutto normale tutto regolare
non spaventatevi non dovete avere paura
e tutto è normale tutto regolare lino
mio papà è ancora chiuso nella sua
stanza ma non dovete avere paura c'è
qualcosa che non cosa forse forse ho
bisogno di alcune spiegazioni
forse preferireste sedervi così vi
racconto un po quello che è successo a
te quello che è successo a mio papà e
magari capirete meglio anche un po la
storia il libro ci ha portato qua per
collezionare i punti per la creatura e
ci siamo ritrovati con dei gal è
trasformato il lupo mannaro e non
abbiamo ancora preso i ponti una volta
presi punti potremmo anche andarsene ma
almeno sentiamo cosa ha da raccontarci
magari racconta qualcosa che riuscirà a
darci punti ricordiamoci anche che c'è
rimasto pochissimo tempo dobbiamo
sbrigarci spesso sentiamo questa ti stai
innanzitutto
com'è possibile che tuo padre che a
quanto ho capito è ancora chiusa la de
trough è un lupo mannaro anzi io
buongiorno ho paura
quindi meglio secondo un occhio quanto
di qua paura che esca da un momento
all'altro
sto facendo buongiorno o no non ci fa
paura
[Applauso]
[Musica]
e non ritornata normale
affatato normale non è
brava brava
ieri notte ai moser vitale che si mi
dispiace accumuliamo sismica
vi spiego tutto no trovare i nostri mesi
al treno
però dobbiamo utilizzare il libro contro
di un ufficio di stefano si librano
quindi loro non fanno i soldi siano solo
secondo in genere il libro crea un video
contro le premature cattive che non
sembra forse non ci beviamo un
tema assolutamente non è più niente ma
vi ricordate ieri segnato davvero
gustare una cucina nel gigante arriva
scaltra e poi dopo ci siamo addormentati
mi ha pure morto e anzi noi ce ne
andiamo se non c'è niente di
importante che io vi spieghi tutto
venite qua devo spiegare tutto vi devo
spiegare tutto vi giuro che non morde
rho più nessuno o in c'e la luce una
cosa che succede solo lì luna piena di
notte forse sta dicendo la verità non mi
sono potuto nome di rino turchi sera la
luna piena e ora è tornato umano ed è
buono quindi noi dobbiamo avere
informazioni sul pon nero per prendere i
punti dobbiamo per forza votarlo se non
so se crederci o no però è la nostra
unica possibilità per conoscere le più
informazioni ma mi vedete sono un uomo
normale sono normalissime ma
effettivamente è vero sembra un nuovo
normale adesso sembra completamente
diverso da com'era ieri è solamente un
incantesimo accomodatevi il papa non si
ricorda quello che è successo ieri notte
e quindi vorrei vorremmo spiegarvi cosa
è successo tanto tempo fa e cosa è
successo stanotte per questo che neanche
tu di tale ti ricordi quello che è
successo ok il signor lino ci sediamo è
però sbrigatevi abbiamo bisogno di
sapere le informazioni prima possibile
anche perché
3 si
cela divinatrice papà mi ha fatto
l'incantesimo non abbiamo molto tempo
più sto cercando la formula per rompere
questo incantesimo
aspettate rilibri
pavia quando cosa succede a
punti ok adesso vi racconto dall'inizio
come sono andate le cose mio padre è
stato maledetto da berenice la
divinatrice non so se voi magari la
conoscete l'avete già sentita nominare
diciamo che l'abbiamo già incontrata e
ci ha lasciato un segno
mio padre come voi alla delle sfide da
affrontare per quanto che non è riuscito
a risolverle tutte e quindi berenice
l'amara letto e lo ha fatto diventare
una delle sue creature
è per questo che ogni luna piena si
trasforma ma proprio un mancino che
stiamo cercando io sto facendo siamo qua
per fare le ricerche però ci manca
ci manca un elemento ci manca qualcosa
ci sono le radici di barzana e
fiorellini di elicriso
il bullo e bargellino
bus
crocus
quindi non avete ancora trovato
l'antidoto che cosa vi manca esattamente
c'è sempre qualcosa che manca siamo
vicini alla formula ma manca forse un
ingrediente fondamentale che non
riusciamo a capire qual è e non lo
troviamo quando troveremo l'ingrediente
mio papà non si trasformerà mai più e
abbiamo appare sempre risolto non
diventerà mai più un lupo mannaro e
potremmo essere felici per sempre
noi abbiamo il libro abbiamo le nostre
libro storie paurose un libro che abbia
i poteri magari si direbbe aiutarvi a
trovare questo antidoto questo
ingrediente non possiamo la nota che
manca perché li possiamo capire qual è
l'ingrediente che manca ma quindi voi
avete delle pozioni che avete già fatto
degli antidoti avete qualcosa si sia
emozionata stico dai far crescere la
facciamo insieme
portiamo unami proveniamo un film usa
c'è scritto ma nella scheda gratuito
vediamo la scheda creatura oppure prima
approviamo le loro pozioni e qui vediamo
la scheda creatura ma ottima idea perché
queste sono le pozioni inagibili questi
sono tutte le ricerche le mie ricerche
di anni che ho fatto bisogna provarle
vitale si sa i filari di me
qualche cosa c'è qualche effetto
particolare ma poi non è molto
importante però dobbiamo dobbiamo
trovare insieme questa questa soluzione
per la nostra salvezza ha detto qualche
effetto particolare
cosa potrebbe succedere
non lo so se ho detto che leggi
approvate che cosa vuoi che succeda
dobbiamo trovare una soluzione perchè tu
sei stato morso è lui a questo
incantesimo quindi deve trovarle
comunque per la festa magari meli stessa
l'onta di un po è forse la cosa giusta
si proviamoli
wow che colore stupendo alice della
siberia alice della siberia
quando lei che mi sentivo male dopo no
allora le possiamo provare adesso che
si
vede oggi si dice ma dai beni
e sono gli effetti che non ci
aspettavamo o no non mi dire capitale
non tornerò mai normale parlerà per
sempre così
[Musica]
[Risate]
[Applauso]
[Musica]
[Risate]
[Applauso]
[Musica]
non vorrei di a mischiare le funzioni
tra di loro mi è rimasto un po di coca
cola io penso che sta rapporto guardare
sicuro se ce la facciamo 331 no paura di
fare l'uomo
questa io non l'ho provata ma che non
l'ha mai provata ok
a goccia
mourinho ha avuto un po di
storia
bellissima senti le pozioni di tuo padre
non hanno funzionato meglio se cerchiamo
una soluzione nel libro che basta con le
funzioni anche io pero smettete di perle
ok avete fatto che troppi disastri oggi
ci siamo divertiti un sacco
secolo ecco lattina creatura allora
vediamo che cosa dice la ferocia di un
licantropo e spaventosa e l'unico modo
per contrastare un suo attacco e
affidarsi alle armi d'argento solo
questo metallo infatti può stordire la
creatura e bloccarne i poteri ma queste
sono tutte informazioni che noi già
sappiamo che cosa potrebbe essere simili
stato conosci benissimo i lupi mannari
famiglie g un attimo lo carico pei
l'argento può bloccare i poteri della
creatura avete mai provato ad irritare
l'argento le vostre emozioni
no ma non abbiamo mai usato la 108
possiamo trovarlo non c'è proprio
l'ingrediente che lancia dobbiamo
cercare i siti ea giorgio lotti potrei
una mozione e la nonna dove sastre si
guardano a bordo
questo no questa mia cugina niente poi
ci sono 90 basta di arminio non è
argento questo malessere d'argento
questo è realista ed argento questo
questo metallo non è argento
forse non c'è niente d'argento come
questo forse questo shooter gente sembra
cento
a me sembra alluminio incontrano antoni
cassetto delle posate si
dovrebbero essere forse qua
no non ce li teniamo qui ho fretta un
momento che cos'ha provato velista
questa collana in argento che potrebbe
essere d'argento sarà rivista
proviamo a emergere la nell'ultimo
antidoto che abbiamo fatto papa l'ultimo
che sembrava funzionare quasi
perfettamente che va dai lavori ma
basterà immergerla
si penso di sì ok diciamo sì certo
e successo a dire proviamo auguriamo che
funzioni forse conviene che l'antidoto
lo beviamo fuori per evitare esplosioni
o se sì perché collaterali troviamo la
storia in bocca al lupo da vasco scusa
hai ragione regionale la forma fortuna
buona fortuna
allora così senti certo bene o se siete
tu sì
[Musica]
adesso siete l'idea che voi potete
proseguire il vostro viaggio si può
continuare la nostra missione dobbiamo
prendere tutti e dieci i punti
altrimenti stato bellissimo bene inizio
si trasformerà in una delle sue creature
andate buona fortuna
grazie grazie melissa ciao ciao milan
capolista
[Musica]
ora il libro dove ci porterà lo
scopriremo nei prossimi episodi
lasciatemi piace cose volete vedere il
continuo e voi ce l'avete il libro
pronti già dalla prossima avventura via
via